[MUSIC PLAYING]
LAURENCE MORONEY: Hi, everybody.
Laurence Moroney from
"The Developer Show."
I'm at the TensorFlow
Developer Summit.
And I'm chatting with Rajat.
Rajat gave part of the
keynote that we had today.
And you spoke a lot
about TensorFlow
and how it's growing so quickly.
Could you tell us all about it?
RAJAT: Sure.
I'm excited.
All the way back from the Middle
East in 2015, it was exciting.
So when we released
this, we were
hoping to really push forward
the research community
and push ML research.
And that's happened,
and that's been great.
That's awesome to see.
But in addition to
that, we've also
seen this huge inflow of
developers who started
to get on machine learning.
And TensorFlow has
made that easier.
And you see some of that in
the numbers and so on as well.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So
before you released it,
did you think it
would be this big?
RAJAT: To be honest, no--
in short.
We did think there was room
for us to make a difference.
And we did think it
would have an impact.
But this has been
huge and amazing.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
And one of the things
you showed during
your talk was a map
of the world with all these
dots of people using TensorFlow.
Isn't it incredible?
RAJAT: It's amazing.
It really highlighted
where all across the world
we're using TensorFlow.
So there were folks all the
way north in the Arctic Circle,
in Tromso, and all the
way south to Antarctica,
Deception Island.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Right.
RAJAT: That was really amazing.
LAURENCE MORONEY: And I
think you said somebody
in every time zone as well.
RAJAT: Exactly.
So pretty much north to
south, left to right,
go across the world-- every
single place in the world.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
But this was people
who had starred it in GitHub.
But it's not just
people starring, right?
There's how many
thousand contributors?
RAJAT: 30,000 commits.
So lots of updates
happening to TensorFlow,
with over 1,400 contributors.
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK.
RAJAT: Right.
And more than 1,000 of those are
actually from outside Google.
So lots of community
involvement there.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So the
majority is outside Google?
RAJAT: Exactly.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Wow.
So any contributors
that come to mind?
Any that have done
amazing things?
RAJAT: So a number
of groups have
supported different
kinds of hardware
and different kinds of
platforms that they run with.
So one example is folks in
other companies, two or three
different companies, in fact--
Uber, Baidu-- and others have
contributed networking stuff.
So really how TensorFlow
shine on different kinds
of distributed systems as well.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Nice.
So it's not just small
people in the community.
It's big companies in the
community, all contributing.
RAJAT: Exactly.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
And then anybody
can take advantage
of that work, right?
RAJAT: Exactly.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Because
it's all open sourced.
And I have to say--
little things.
I made my first
contribution just last week.
RAJAT: Awesome.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Yeah, there was
a little bug in the readme
for tfFlight that I saw.
And the process of contributing
was actually very, very easy.
RAJAT: Absolutely.
That's our goal.
We love the community
participation,
and we are making
it even easier.
LAURENCE MORONEY: What
would you do to encourage
developers to get involved?
What would you ask
developers to do
to get involved, to contribute,
or any of those kind of things?
RAJAT: So there
are lots of things.
There are issues on GitHub
that you can look at.
There are lots of them
that you can start with.
Let's say you're
using TensorFlow
and you find a problem.
Just go ahead and fix it.
It's very easy to get started.
And it can be as tiny
as a one line change
to the readme, like
you were saying,
or some real code changes, or
even some much bigger thing
as well.
All are possible.
We have lots of
developers doing that.
LAURENCE MORONEY: And it was
a very welcoming community.
I mean, my experience was
great because somebody
has to review my changes.
They reviewed it, they
passed it, it got checked in.
And it was a beautiful thing.
RAJAT: That's great.
I'm glad you had a
great experience.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
And I'm sure you can
have a great experience too.
Just give it a shot.
So thank you so much, Rajat.
This has been a real pleasure.
I really appreciate
everything that you've
been doing to the community.
And thanks, everybody,
for watching this episode
of "The Developer Show."
I'm Laurence Moroney.
If you've any questions
for me, if you
have any questions
for Rajat, just
please leave them in
the comments below.
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]